uh
so this is uh from crying shark and
this is joe rogan being fake to the
undertaker after trashing wrestling for
years so let's
let's we we're going to play this we
never got it i was always wondering how
that episode was going to go because i
don't watch rogan anyway
check it out there's nothing wrong with
being gay nothing
and there's nothing wrong with being a
fan
of pro wrestling
but it's the same thing and thanks for
coming on here i really
really appreciate it ah thanks for
having me man yeah it's an honor really
oh my pleasure honored to have you
there's that stigma that mma
was was it kind of is it like wrestling
you know and everybody's like [ __ ] no
it's not like wrestling
that's a goddamn same one of them is
real
one of them people that's what i said
battling for their life
in the most difficult contest mma people
are a little more sensitive about
it another one is some weird this is a
great cut i love this already
[ __ ] jerk-off thing that strange
guys do when they sit in front of the tv
and pretend they don't know it's fake
didn't you used to do jiu-jitsu while
listening to gangster
with another dude because i remember
when you're on o a remember when he
talked about that we
was him and eddie bravo used to do jiu
jitsu in his garage while listening to
gangster
let me care if he kept calling wrestling
lame but he keeps pressing the gay issue
and it's like
joe yeah nobody has more closeted
homosexual tendencies than you
guys do when they sit in front of the tv
and pretend they don't know it's fake
they get all up in arms uh
why you got that fake [ __ ] wrestler
on there right
dude yeah you can't worry about those
people no i don't worry about them
there's people that love
real you can't worry about those people
you're those people joe still fighting
that have a
real hard time with these fake
wwe style scenarios i don't like
that kind of [ __ ] bleeding into mma i
think it's dumb
you think it's dumb but that's been
happening in mma for
years they they
they yell at each other on twitter and
they have since the beginning of [ __ ]
ufc
they they all work at a box even before
mma
boxing used to do that boxers used to
[ __ ] yell at each other and scream at
each other on purpose before fights to
hype it up
i don't like that kind of [ __ ] bleeding
into mma i think it's dumb
there's millions and millions of wwe and
i'm telling you why
maybe hunter s thompson was just a
couple of decades off when he was
predicting the end of the world yeah how
big is [ __ ] wrestlemania
that's crazy huge that is crazy
when you look at that many people there
for that they come what a successful
[ __ ] event
what else shawn that audience a [ __ ]
simple card trick
hey this is every everyman joe rogan
okay
to come i know you're not a i know
you're not a wrestling fan i know
wrestling is gayer than musicals how
about that i'll take acid and go how
about i
brother i guarantee you you're gonna see
what happens at wrestlemania i mean
there's something
highlights [ __ ] is wrong with you
i guarantee you you'll have a good time
i would go if i'm home if
i'm around i just i never know where i'm
at it's hard
what do you mean you never know where
you're at i mean you haven't left texas
and you're the boss yeah you can do
whatever you want like
like you're right in that yeah i don't
know where i'm gonna be next week or
what i'm doing but like
if somebody called me and said yo oh
yeah it's actually coming up next week
somebody said she want to go to
wrestlemania i got an extra ticket
i'll just call royce i'd be like i'm not
coming in tomorrow i go to
wrestlemania like you know what i mean
there's no [ __ ] there's still a
thousand tickets left
so i'm not going i'm not paying to go to
russia but i mean like if somebody went
hey man i got a box or whatever you want
to go to mania i'd be like
ah whatever but like i look at he's
pretending like yeah i would go like
you know only i could just get away from
work and it's like you're the but you
could
you're you are work you could tell
everyone to go home
joe it's hard to give a [ __ ]
about fake fights fan or not a fan you
will have a good time
i'm sure i've been telling him this for
years hopefully you get it
i'd go [ __ ] crazy and i'd watch lions
killing gazelles on television because
that's real
that's what i do i'd grab my laptop and
i'd be like yeah you watch this fake
[ __ ] all day i need real
i need real i can't get in watching by
things die
i'm sorry why why do you want to watch
things it's what i don't understand
and also like i know this is an old
wrestling defense
talking point but like do you go to
movie show
have you been to an avengers movie have
you been to
i mean how many movies have we seen over
the years that are
very clearly like i know that star-lord
can't fly through space without any sort
of oxygen apparatus and just live
i know that but it's better to just
pretend
for the for the two hours guardians is
on and go this is fun
right and the way that you pretend
brendan chav is funny like
you pretend he's hilarious and you got
him a showtime special so like the way
you do that you can pretend on other
things you pretend he's a fighter
yeah you pretend he's a comedian yeah
you pretend he's a good dresser
you pretend he's cool yeah oh my god
that is so crazy
100 jesus christ 5 000 people
oh that's so many people
seventy so thousand yeah you have to cut
it down with vince and vince's math is
not always the best
it's just the size of that ground you
know what i would do if i worked for the
irs
is i would just start auditing at wwe
it'd be like something's not adding up
with your with your crowd numbers versus
the money you're reporting
and just watch how quickly like vince
has to start going
sixty eight thousand come on
[Laughter]
it starts costing him money he'll be
like all right 68.
my god that's that'd be amazing if you
were there physically no
when you're watching the wwe you know
that it's scripted no disrespect to the
wrestlers or anything like that but
one of the reasons why the audience will
act like that's because they they could
feel that it's not real it's all for
sure
you somebody here dirk digler says
undertaker would beat joe's ass in her
life
the undertaker can barely walk anymore
yeah
maybe in their prime at a different time
and place
maybe but the undertaker
is he's in hulk hogan shape now like
he's in
bad hips people that see him go like
yeah he was a really nice guy but he's
not moving like
he's not moving like the 1990 purple
gloves undertaker
they're like trying to suck excitement
out of out of the air yeah oh my god
so you know who works harder than pro
wrestlers
what an ass kisser i ate but this is
look it doesn't matter i mean there's a
lot of people don't like wrestling than
watching that's fine if you don't like
wrestling that's fine you think it's gay
i don't care
i probably think some of the things you
like are gay but
this isn't this isn't a defensive
wrestling this is just to show you what
joe rogan is
like literally i'd rather watch like a
really good
fiction and somewhere i know it's going
to be good yeah all the time
not every now and then the guy tries to
mouth [ __ ] a dude with a sock on his
hand
you talking about mick foley the dude
that has lost an
ear in a tooth and and [ __ ] [ __ ] up
his entire body
yeah a man who is despite becoming a
complete [ __ ] and he is a cop
uh still manages to be one of the most
charitable nice people
always raising money for complete
strangers like
he say whatever you want about mick
foley but i mean that [ __ ] guy
like came from nothing didn't look like
[ __ ]
and still became a huge star
well no wonder why so many guys have a
problem with pills too because you're in
a constant state of pain
absolutely brock lesnar beat the
undertaker nobody thought it was gonna
happen
oh my god what did they do tony imagine
if on
saturday the [ __ ] is wrong with you this
is how i feel watching your show a lot
joe it's like oh my god really you got
an assault tank wow that's so cool
oh wow you took dmt why don't you tell
your same dmt story for the 50th time
joe
that's super cool because every man
loves to hear about it
oh you have another guy that run three
marathons in a row ooh
captivating oh you're elk hunting
buddies there
tell me how [ __ ] awesome elk mead is
i mean come on that's just as boring joe
it's [ __ ] boring
you imagine somebody in the chat pointed
out the guy joe was talking to threw
mick foley off the top of a steal
it's a really good point oh my god
you're right i thought it was gonna
happen
it was amazing it was fake as [ __ ] dude
is there anybody that gets your pro
wrestling without
a series of catastrophic joe's looking a
little um
a little pudgy little time to be pudgy a
little bit
again 2015 i wrestle lesnar at
wrestlemania
and uh the superdome somewhere in the
first five minutes or so of the match i
get concussed
yeah you can i don't even buy that
that's right i remember that
[ __ ] tanker didn't remember anything
after 3 p.m because he got concussed so
bad
boy was a real concussion okay they
probably faked a concussion
i mean at that point he's just breaking
balls i know i know it's just funny
though thank you
they gotta take the undertaker to the
hospital he's got a boo-boo
okay well this is now actually
specifically getting very smooth whoever
cut this up is
crying shark shout out to crying crying
shark you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i hope that i never ever
piss you off
where they take me to the hospital they
took the undertaker and put a band-aid
on him come out
it's the same kind of deal they go all
right uh
he he's broken his neck went to the
hospital
with the undertaker because he cried so
hard he dehydrated himself after that
match
they had to give him an iv to replenish
his two he thought he killed the
undertaker
from that concussion it was an old break
that i never knew i had
yeah yeah see you had a break you just i
never still wrestling with it and i
never knew it oh my god
it's a real boo-boo folks if you don't
think it's a real boo-boo i'll show you
the [ __ ] band-aid on it
it's just incredible that you can do
that and then still wrestle
i mean yeah you're jumping onto a
cushion how crazy that my kids do that
yeah my mom is a place down the street
from here there's trampolines and they
have cushions
i'm sorry does he think the the little
one-inch mat that they're jumping on is
like a big cushion
also i mean you say whatever you want
about pro wrestlers but
they have probably one of the most
brutal
scares well wwe ones do have the most
brutal schedule that you've ever seen in
your life
mma guy fight like they fight every six
months yep
guy zone an eight year stretch where i
average 270 dates a year there you go
that's what a lot of people don't they
don't they don't get that part of what
we get the live events
town to town flying everywhere that is
bananas yeah that shit's getting
out these dudes are hugging they get all
sweaty they're laying on each other
they're and and it's not real there's
some crazy submission moves that uh no
no no no no that's the last thing
let me tell you something that's the
last thing you want to show me
don't that'll get me angry see here's
why this is so [ __ ] stupid
the guy in black is no no the guy in
black has a better position
wow that's crazy changed the name of the
hell's gate
what are they doing winners are losers
everybody gets a trophy is that what
you're doing
so you would grab them by the back of
the head and run your shin
underneath their neck it's [ __ ]
right it's fast
yeah it's offensive yeah and the idea
there's other moves that happen that are
amazing no no no
they're all they're all offensive they
take athleticism to pull off
but they're offensive because i'm so
aware it's so in my face that this is
not really happening jesus christ
yeah just seeing that makes me shiver oh
that's when lesnar got the [ __ ]
broke his neck at the concussion that
image
oh no oh sorry austin broke his neck
who works harder than pro wrestlers like
literally i can't
i can't watch somebody breaking their
leg for a play it's essentially a play
imagine if there's a play where you
break your leg all that all that stuff
is what makes you you
and when it's all said and done your 30
plus years in the game
you can look back on that and go i
earned every
[ __ ] ounce of this who knows man it's
all plot lines for those folks maybe i'm
a commentator on pro wrestling
maybe this is all some [ __ ] phony
horseshit and i'm caught up in this
pretending it's all real and
legitimizing this horseshit
thanks joe thanks joe
that's he i mean he'll
honestly it's just don't be fake though
just don't be fake save the taker's face
man yeah say this [ __ ] to his face